about the drama part yeah part
healthy women women always go back to
what's normal to them yeah everybody can
like a little bit of drama but a healthy
woman such as yourself if a man keeps on
cheating on her calling you out your
name you ain't staying there but a girl
came from a broken background a broken
household where that's normal that is
home for her women always go back home
so to your point yes some women do like
a very toxic unhealthy drama but I would
argue women like yourself who come from
healthy backgrounds is only so much
drama they can take before they're going
to lead this individual yeah you know I
think you're right I just think like
this isn't this is very honest and it
probably makes me look bad but like I
think on some level women like drama
like in general so in general so I'm
gonna give you one of my theories I've
been working on free game to the people
explains why women like drama usually
wear drama yeah I call this high value
man insecurity I hate using the word
high value man things a terrible word
it's been wasted all I just can't say
it's not our dad I'm I'm gonna use it
for the sake of this conversation high
value man insecurity there is a natural
drama that a woman has when she's around
a very successful man give it a case in
point let's say you meet your husband
tall handsome successful doing well in
life you and your husband go into a a
room right let's say you're at a Gallop
he's handsome you know that he's
handsome all of a sudden you see all
these women looking at your husband you
walk in the room something in you as a
woman just starts getting a little
jealous a little territory it feels kind
of way holding on to him a little bit
more yeah back off [ __ ] exactly back
off then all of a sudden right he has
he's a successful man he has to go meet
the People Meet the donors meet the
people in the room he has to go and talk
to people yeah your husband goes he's
talking to people talking to this guy
talking to this guy but he's not rude
he's not sexist he has talked to the
women as well he starts talking to the
women all of a sudden that same girl is
giving you dirty looks he's he's a man
he didn't notice it but you noticed it
yeah she's now talking to him and she's
laughing and giggling and flirting he's
just being kind begin the drama episode
two of season 17 of pearly's marriage
now this bi is now trying to take my man
yeah Begins the drama now you're mad at
now you're mad at her but you also mad
at him why are you talking to him why is
that in the third dagger for just
talking
um trust me because you because you're
gonna be upset because like you should
see that she's flirting with you oh okay
you're like you're I'm like yeah come on
come on stop playing this game you know
how it is why are you every five minutes
a lot of games I play so so what ends up
happening is that that gives you a
little bit of insecurity that insecurity
makes you feel kind of way you start
playing scenarios in your brain that
creates the drama so there's things that
are natural these are natural behaviors
that when you're with a very successful
very attractive man you will feel and
those men whether they're good or bad or
in between they make women feel that way
and that behavior makes you at times
cling closer to that guy because if
every other girl in the room wants them
you definitely don't want other girls to
beat you yeah they call it um I forgot
the term is but it's like it's like when
girls prefer the guys that like the
girls want yeah yeah so that's an
example of like crazy drama you're not
do you not understand though um because
back to something where
we were too like you men get a bad deal
today when it comes to marriage a
hundred percent men get bad deals when
it comes to marriage but who is signing
those deals you see I'm a solution
oriented person yeah I no I know I just
want to I just of course so you do agree
with me that okay do men get bad deals
okay but here's the reality yeah do all
men get bad deals let's let's explain
you so one of the conversations that
people have is about the prenup yeah
you're in UK you know this
and and correctly correct me if I'm
wrong because I don't notice all the top
of my head so I'm I don't know this
study yeah maybe you've noticed better
than I do I saw a study where it said
women from 20 to 29 in UK are starting
to out earn men have you seen that study
before yeah I've heard of I've heard
I've heard that in major I actually
didn't hear about that one but I heard
it a major cities in the major cities
yeah so right so Matt Google women were
out guys yeah I love it
so think about that so there are some
men right now who are dating women who
out earned them is safe to say yes so if
that guy gets married to that woman and
they get divorced they don't sign a
prenup who gets most who's winning that
deal the person with less money so for
some guys it is a good deal well but men
only win 13 of alimony cases no I didn't
say alimony okay alimony is a totally
different thing because that's a rare
occasion because think about it to get
like you want to go down there I mean
but like even if we if we did
um like like the way it would be split
up do you really think men are gonna get
the bad or the women are going to get
the bad if you're dating a doctor I knew
a guy right now dating a doctor is
making 410 000 a year this guy is an
audio engineer making about fifty
thousand dollars a year so when they
split their assets in the divorce case
as I've seen in other situations and
this one woman actually called me in for
a session describing what happened the
the man is going to get more than what
he then what he came in with that's why
they tell heiresses to sign contracts
they tell heiresses to always that
contract to prenups because they said yo
our family got all this money we don't
want that man coming in and taking it so
in some cases yes I'm not saying it's
most I'm not saying it's all in some
cases yes and so therefore there are
some situations where women men are
getting better deals if you are a guy
and and most girls and you can't get sex
consistently and all of a sudden you
find a girl and you convince a girl to
want to be with you even though she's
not really happy and you're getting sex
occasionally you are getting the better
deal because in the free market you
couldn't get sex
um consistently so for some guys the sex
that they're getting they could not get
that in the free market and so one of
mine
listen
every man is not the kind of guy who's
like I'm gonna pay a hooker every single
twice at once a week once every other
week I understand that man just like
gosh you're gonna you're gonna marry her
and sign that contracts every now and
how many men are signing how many men
are signing getting married because
they're having sex what do we talk about
that's the world we're living in all of
them I'm just thinking like that's a
horrible deal of course and that's a
horrible thing and now what did I tell
you the men are signing those bad deals
yeah so to me here's my here's my rule
of thumb with Mary this is why like I
said I'm a little bit nuanced yeah I
view success successful marriage as
successful businessmen you have a
successful YouTube channel but you know
the analytics more than everybody else
how many percent of YouTube channels
have 10 000 subscribers how many have a
hundred thousand subscribers how many
500 000 subscribers you can look it up
right now on social Blaze analytics and
you can be able to see that you are part
of the 0.1 of one percent of content
creators you are at the top of the
mountain but guess what happens what is
your third tier on patreon that you're
doing third tier of your all of his
YouTube memberships or patreon serious
social media social media and what are
you helping them with oh that's the
first tier I know third tier is when you
said you're helping them with social
media isn't it no it's like you connect
on social media okay the fourth tier is
one-on-one coaching yeah yeah so why are
people calling you because they want to
get to where you're at yeah they want to
get to the point one percent of the
point one percent point one percent yeah
do you tell them hey the reality is 99
of people will never get here so stop
wasting your time no you say you know
even if most people are not gonna get
here I'm gonna help you get there so for
me there are people who are who are
married right now I'm not sure if your
parents are still married or not here
they are shout out to your beautiful
chairs they have 10 kids too beautiful
yeah I love it all yeah yeah there are
people like your parents and my parents
who've been who are living happy healthy
marriages right my biggest thing is I
want to create more of that I know it's
the exception not the rule I want to
create more that the same way there's a
limited amount of millionaires but we
still want to all aspire to be
millionaires yeah I want to Aspire for
the best yeah no and I I agree with you
but like I just I just really understand
the guys when they they want to walk
away because I just when I walk into
ways for quitters but when I hear these
law at least legally at least legally
because when I hear these laws I'm like
this is crazy you can protect yourself
from these things it's the year 2000 see
here's my problem I listen being black
in America you don't get victim Hood
excuses you don't get things whine and
complain you see the biggest problem
especially with a lot of these red pill
mantle Spirit manosphere kind of guys is
they get to play the victim all this all
day long being being black in America
there's no excuses and I don't care the
laws I don't care what the police says I
don't care who's racist I don't care
make it work make it work so women like
you in all due respect you guys oh my
gosh the poor guys and they have so it's
so hard for them man that's life that is
life let me finish that is life for a
man it is extremely difficult it is
extremely challenging bad things happen
to you and you have to learn how to
overcome it it is the year 2022. I
understand in the year 1992 when bad
things were happening that you had
nothing to do with it now there is so
many tools resources online to be able
to protect yourself and prevent these
things from happening those old school
messages are not relevant in 2022 in the
information era as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible